When you're looking at the Sagittarius constellation
you're actually looking into the center of
our galaxy.
Steve Carell never watched more than 10 minutes
of the original Office, for fear of copying
Rickey Gervais' character.
In 1963, baseball pitcher Gaylord Perry remarked,
'They'll put a man on the moon before I hit
a home run.'
On July 20, 1969, less than an hour after
Neil Armstrong had set foot on the moon, Gaylord
Perry hit his first home run.
Bugs Bunny was the second cartoon character
to receive a star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame; the first was Mickey Mouse.
A troop of 15 monkeys escaped a primate research
centre in Japan by using trees as catapults
over a 5-metre high electric fence.
They were lured back afterwards with peanuts.
In the 16th century, gin was referred to as
“mother's ruin” because people thought
it could induce an abortion.
A restaurant in Grantham, England makes the
world's hottest curry.
Called “The Widower”, it contains 20 Naga
Infinity Chillis and chefs have to wear goggles
to prepare it.
300 people have failed to eat the dish, most
leave crying, shaking and vomiting.
Only one person has ever finished the entire
dish, a doctor who took 1 hour to eat it and
spent 10 full minutes hallucinating due to
the chilis.
Michael Crichton, author of Jurassic Park,
felt his professor was giving him unfair grades.
To prove it he turned in a paper by George
Orwell and received a B-.
There is one lawyer for every 19 residents
in Washington DC.
About 75% of the world's food is generated
from only 12 plants and 5 animal species.
In order to legally adopt a child from Korea,
the adopting parents cannot have a BMI of
more than 35.
In Japan a few foreign cartoons have been
edited including “Bob The Builder”, to
add a fifth finger to the character's hands.
The reason is that having only four fingers
in Japan implies one is part of the Japanese
mafia.
J.R.R.
Tolkien taught himself Finnish at 18, just
so he could read one book, the Kalevala, which
he used as a basis for Middle Earth legendarium.
In 2017, Norway will be the first country
in the world to completely shut down FM radio
and go digital.
Norway plans to switch to DAB since FM radio
is eight times more expensive.
During WWII, La-Z-Boy manufactured seats for
tanks, torpedo boats, gun turrets, and armoured
cars.
In 2009, a man named Felix Batista, who was
an expert on how to avoid being kidnapped
in Mexico was kidnapped in Mexico after giving
a lecture on “How to not be kidnapped
in Mexico”.